so let's take a look at some of the
acquisitions and the velocity they
they put somebody in charge uh the
periscope co-founder
kayvon uh bakepour who's gonna be on
this
uh podcast soon maybe next week or two
weeks he's uh
k-a-y-v-z on twitter he's pretty awesome
he's the head of consumer products
and he joined in 2015 after they um
bought
periscope before it launched which is it
was a great product
and then he became the head of product
in a june 2018 reorg by jack
periscope was officially sunset and shut
down um just on march 31st of this year
and uh like i said cave is coming on the
podcast but let's look at the
the product velocity here they launched
spaces back in november 2020 i was lucky
enough to be part of that um they can be
started by anyone now with over 600
followers it's a direct competitor to
clubhouse i would argue it's better than
clubhouse because
you can be on twitter and share tweets
while this is playing like in a
minimized tray at the bottom of the app
which is
really cool because what most people are
doing on clubhouse is leaving clubhouse
and opening twitter
and you know reading tweets while
talking on clubhouse is
um now in one specific space and
you don't have to rebuild your followers
and you get to just
everybody who's on twitter automatically
sees you hanging out there now it's not
working on the web yet it's not working
on ipad
so there's a lot of growth left for
twitter spaces i think twitter spaces
will have many more users in clubhouse
ultimately
uh super follows this was announced on
february 25th and it's going to let
users earn money
from followers who pay them for
exclusive content ecommerce deals or
other perks
you know this will be kind of like
patreon we actually shut our patreon
down recently because
many of you didn't know about it we're
trying to get you to go over patreon
maybe we'll relaunch that we'll see but
we'll probably relaunch that natively on
apple and spotify
which are offering um ad-free
subscriptions
which i think one percent of you will
probably take advantage of
but you never know maybe we'll do some
content here we generally don't like to
charge our users we have great
advertisers and partners so
this isn't as relevant for us but you
could see it being relevant for
the only fans crowd or the sub stack
crowd
or certain uh content that is not
advertiser friendly
and you can see other influencers making
money from this
so uh the idea here would be you get
subscriber only newsletters you know
access to different
communities that you wouldn't have
access to or deals and discounts that
kind of stuff
the standard cohort of things on patreon
and this means you don't again have to
leave twitter so if you want to hold the
space you want to do a newsletter you
want to have an audio space a newsletter
a patreon you're basically building sub
stack patreon
and spaces into twitter where your graph
is
and where everybody's spending time and
that really is going to make a
difference because people switching apps
is a cost people having to download apps
having to create a patreon account this
is all nonsense and takes too much time
if everything is in one app
it's much much more like it is in china
where you have singular apps that have
many features in them
youtube added a premium uh membership
you might
have become aware of so when you have on
a lot of youtube channels you'll see
subscribe and join join means you pay
subscribe means you get it for free
so again patreon i'm short patreon
because
why would anybody go start a patreon if
it's built in youtubers
there's no reason to start a patreon and
a podcaster now with
apple and spotify offering subscriptions
and with twitter offering subscriptions
really
why would you even need to go there and
that's not a dick to patreon it's an
interesting service and they obviously
pioneered it
but it does show exactly you know how
your startup can become a feature of
another one
channels can add exclusive videos
members only content yada yada
tip jar i just turned this on i just got
an alert about it i'm going to donate
all my
my tips to charity but this lets you
connect
your twitter handle to things like the
cash app
which obviously jack owns as part of
square patreon paypal venmo bandcamp and
some other services
and twitter takes no cut which is a
really interesting concept so they're
undercutting other people
and i think the tip jar could become a
really powerful concept i
watch a number of online youtube live
shows knicks fan tv
scott adams um his morning show at 7 a.m
and i see people give five dollars ten
dollars twenty five dollars
to these uh live streams
and then it's got a really neat thing it
the the
on youtube i recently gave a 50
tip uh to my friend cp of the franchise
who does knicks fan tv because it's so
entertaining
i just thought i'll just throw him 50
bucks and he can buy a bottle of
chardonnay
because after the next game i like to
watch his post game commentary it's like
buy the fans for the fans so i give them
the 50 bucks and i didn't realize this
but my 50
tip with my name stayed up on the screen
for 30 minutes i think
if you put like a 10 tip it stays up for
10 minutes five dollars stays up for
five minutes you get the idea
so you kind of get this really nice
recognition by doing this obviously this
exists in other places
and tipping super big in china du yin
is how it's pronounced i believe owned
by by dance collected 1.7 billion
in tipping revenue in the first half of
2020 according to my notes here other
services like twitch uh
have tipping for a long time you all
know that